happy Mother's Day mom and then she
replies you've been hanging over too
many white people hahahaha none me and
my mom sex like every day I try to talk
to my mom at least every other day maybe
three or four times a week she texts me
like maybe once a day she wants me to
text her every day though she uses
question will punctuation like way too
many exclamation points and question
marks just excessive amounts every
single time I text her about a mention
I'm going out with a girl she will
almost always say something very
uncomfortably creepy like she has texted
me the words get it looks like i said my
bumper got crashed into again and she
responded are you serious for question
marks hit and run three question marks
you need to move three exclamation
points ahead please get the following
things from the union shop cooking oil G
multigrain art opening I love the red
powder chili lime seasoning that you
sprinkle on fruits and stuff it's called
ticking and my mom was at the grocery
store and asked me what is that red
powder you used to sprinkle on Cornish
malvinas roasted chana dal dal dal again
I said I love you forever mom and she
didn't respond for two weeks and then
she responded ok onions garlic ginger
coriander leaves Matheny dolly what size
of the panties are you usually from
Victoria's Secret they're on the
semi-annual sale now I want to buy a few
was still not enough for free shipping
Beason koya and other vegetables yes I
know you're in Buffalo but remember to
commit suicide and Buffalo is redundant
she says what are you up to tonight I
said going on a date with a girl pretty
excited she said tell her you have a cat
to trick her into going into your house
yep my mom is probably gonna watch this
and cry and probably like slapping it on
the side of my head like why would you
share that but I those are the parts
that make me love her one even though
I'm kind of making funny you never
change and two you're my favorite mom
but also at least favorite I guess by
virtue of their being done other moms